welcome to this video plane our rosters
from Cyprus yeah cyprus then having a
hood sneaky I'm sorry for them for the
noise it was a bit surprised how quickly
this game materialized came let's play
as imageshack always leading to
interesting play and it's probably going
from the main line with b6 yep 98 now
seems to know seems to know the line now
on usually f5 is played now you can also
many other sizes also a possibility but
it is really risky it seems playable but
it is very risky I have analysed I had
analyzed this for my map for my book
project and at the end decided that I
cannot recommend this for black because
of exactly this after f5 you need to
play f6 ready this this now is some
really really dangerous Knight f6 Bishop
g5 is almost lost i think and GF data
page six at least which they exchanged
probably more this is very very very bad
for black let's see
yeah probably this is the easiest still
should be precise you can easily spoil
it night g3 to h5 on our walk first
that's probably both good let's let's
start with the rook and make sure not to
lose on time this combines rook h3g
three ideas with rook f1 the main issue
is that i have this attack going and he
has got the night on e5 which does not
help at all with defense this King
position is really weak
the main threat really is Queenie three
yeah let's go ahead with rook f6 coming
it's hard to make a knot protect this
pawn and if you place f5 I take and yeah
this just getting I can take f7 I can
play if IE fibers even stronger night F
for being a very very substantial threat
yeah I drew got seven of course sir
another threat yeah
yeah probably will try see for Quincy to
and then then there is no move I can
take now hand let's see Brooke check and
clean f3 probably check and then the
queen of six and can you cannot cover
that or is the batter move Queen f3
it's enough it's enough I can play can
play a coinky but against that I have
from work T cell if everything else
fails I hope do some check and now look
f7 next move is curtains yeah this is a
one hundred percent opening disaster
it's in fact unknown attacking motif the
southpaw and push it's a bit unlucky
that he ran right into into my book
analysis basically well I had a head
check this form check like and as
mentioned decided that it's it's too
risky and we we saw quite um check
drastically widest to risk him black
resigned yeah I mean I had analyzed the
slide up to white playing f5 and they
came to the conclusion that black must
play f6 here that's here f6 and this is
in fact not so clear I mean I I still
thought it is too risky for for black
but this is a playable line what can can
play something like this night f4 and
then Queen h5 rook f3h really is kind of
caveman attack but it's very dangerous
like most likely we'll have to play h6
which further weakens the the light
squares and this was some very very
tough to analyze for black so there at
the end I decided I
should not put it in the book black
young has a much easier defense with f5
which has a pretty solid reputation and
this is some fine and here after f6 I
think black is basically toast maybe you
can can cook up some kind of vague
defense with the computer but I doubt it
and you know in a human game I I doubt
that you can you can remotely defend
this f ck h 6 does not help but does
this thread conference to play this move
but again I play this intending night h5
so that you probably need to do it
anyway and here yeah a number of a
number of good lines Creed III for
example now here it can maybe play a 5
ok so we be cautious conference to play
this move strangely enough I don't
really understand it it gives a wider
pretty clear that I do understand i mean
why it should be good anyway at some but
not quite sure what d5 is really doing
my knight c6 may be controlling this he
continues just with rook f2 and rook
everyone I mean white is to pants down
so the computer giving white um plus 0.6
is quite substantial yeah one in a
practical game is this is this is just
terrible maybe the comp can can find
some elaborate way to to not lose it but
it's it's very tough yeah the score is
increasing I have this position still um
yeah on the comp [ __ ] calculating and it
gives it its no one plus one yeah it is
very dangerous alright thanks for
watching